>> Tucker: ACCORDING TO A
RECENT REPORT HERE AT FOX,
REPUBLICAN LEADERS HAVE A SECRET
PLAN TO WIN THE 22 MIDTERMS.
INSTEAD OF TELLING REPORTER
INSTEAD OF TELLING REPORTER    V
INSTEAD OF TELLING REPORTER    T
INSTEAD OF TELLING REPORTER    R
INSTEAD OF TELLING REPORTER
INSTEAD OF TELLING REPORTER    H
INSTEAD OF TELLING REPORTER    T
THEY WOULD DO
, THE APPEAL IS OBVIOUS, NOBLY
LIKES HILLARY CLINTON, EVEN
PEOPLE WHO WERE PAID TO PRETEND
THEY LIKE HER.
THE DOWNSIDE IS IT'S NOT REALLY
A RELEVANT ARGUMENT.
HILLARY CLINTON CAN'T RUN
ANYTHING ANYMORE.
SHE DOESN'T REPRESENT THE PARTY,
THEY'VE MOVED ON TO ANOTHER
PLANET AND THAT'S THE POINT.
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS ARE NOW
SAYING THINGS FAR MORE EXTREME
THAN ANYTHING LIKE
HILLARY CLINTON EVER WOULD HAVE
SAID OR THOUGHT.
THEY BECOME OPENLY BIGOTED FOR
EXAMPLE BLAMING AN ENTIRE ETHNIC
GROUP FOR THE COUNTRY'S
PROBLEMS.
THEY'VE CALLED ILLUMINATING OUR
COUNTRY'S BORDERS THE RIGHT TO
SELF-DEFENSE, EVEN DISTINCT IN
BETWEEN MALE AND FEMALE.
THEY'RE AGITATING FOR AN ACTUAL
WAR AGAINST RUSSIA.
THEY'RE INSANE.
SOME ARE DANGEROUS AND SOMEBODY
OUGHT TO RUN AGAINST THEM, NOT
THE GHOST OF SOME ELDERLY
NOMINEE FROM LAST CYCLE.
YET SOMEHOW, THE REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS SAY THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO DO THAT.
ARE THEY?
WE HAVE SOMEONE TO TELL US.
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN'S
REPUBLIC AND WHO REPRESENTS OHIO
REPUBLIC AND WHO REPRESENTS OHI
OHIO.
I DON'T WANT TO POOH-POOH THE
IDEA OF HILLARY.
HER SEGMENTS ARE HILARIOUS, BUT
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF RIGHT
NOW IS NOT THE PARTY OF
HILLARY CLINTON.
IT'S AN OPENLY EXTREMIST, RACIST
PARTY I WOULD ARGUE AND I THINK
IT'S OBVIOUS THAT REPUBLICANS IN
OPPOSITION SHOULD RUN AGAINST
THEM, BUT WHY AREN'T THEY?
>> I WOULD SAY LET'S RUN FOR
WHAT WE THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO
DO IN '16, LET'S RUN ON WHAT
WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED.
'17 WAS A GOOD YEAR.
REGULATIONS WERE DOWN, THE TAXES
WERE LOWERED, THE ECONOMY HAS
GROWN, EMBASSIES GOING TO
JERUSALEM, THAT WAS A PRETTY
GOOD YEAR.
THERE ARE LOTS OF REPUBLICANS
WHO THINK BEING OUR BEST FRIEND
AND ALLY MAKES SENSE.
EVERY OTHER -- ALL I'M SAYING IS
2017 WAS A GOOD YEAR.
THIS SPENDING BILL THAT WE
PASSED FOUR WEEKS AGO IS NOT
WHAT WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING.
IT NEVER HURTS TO KEEP YOUR
PROMISES, NEVER HURTS TO DO WHAT
YOU THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING TO DO
AND GO RUN ON THAT AND RUN
AGAINST WHAT THE HARD LEFT IS
PUSHING AND THEIR PARTY.
>> Tucker: IF YOU HAD A
POLITICAL PARTY THAT LITERALLY
WANTED TO A LIMITED THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN MEN AND
WOMEN AND PRETEND THAT NATURE
WASN'T REAL, I HAVEN'T HEARD
THAT.
MEN AND WOMEN ARE DIFFERENT,
IT'S A BIOLOGICAL FACT.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE GOT TO THE
POINT WHERE THEY ARE ATTACKING
PEOPLE, TRYING TO GET THEM FIRED
FOR JOBS FOR ACKNOWLEDGING THEIR
BIOLOGICAL DIFFERENCES.
>> ENTER GOING ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES NOT LETTING
CONSERVATIVE CHRISTIANS OR
ANTI-SEMITIC'S -- THEY'RE
ATTACKING THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES,
HOW RADICAL AND ANTI-SEMITIC AND
ANTI-BASIC FUNDAMENTAL BELIEFS
IT IS.
I'M ALL FOR THAT AS WELL, BUT
LET'S GO DO WHAT WE TOLD HIM WE
WERE GOING TO DO, WHAT THEY
ELECTED US TO DO IN NOVEMBER OF
2016 AND LET'S DO WITH THE --
>> Tucker: THE 2016 ELECTION
IF YOU COULD ISOLATE ONE PROMISE
WOULD BE THE WALL.
THAT'S BEEN THE ONE CONSISTENTLY
BY CONGRESS.
>> THERE ARE THINGS LIKE THE
WALL, IT WAS A $1.3 TRILLION
BILL THAT WE HAD 15 HOURS TO
LOOK AT, 2,200 PAGES AND THE
DEBATE WAS ONE HOUR.
WE GO HOME FOR EASTER RECESS
AFTER THAT, WE COME BACK, WE
HAVE FOUR HOURS TO DEBATE A
THREE-PAGE BILL WHICH WAS A
GREAT IDEA, BUT SOMETHING
EVERYONE KNOWS WILL NOT GET
THROUGH CONGRESS AND BECOME LAW,
WE DEBATE THAT FOR 4 HOURS.
THAT'S WHAT DRIVES AMERICAN
VOTERS CRAZY.
NO WONDER THEY'RE CYNICAL ABOUT
CAPITOL HILL, AND WHAT THEY SEE.
THAT'S THE KIND OF STUFF THAT
HAS TO CHANGE BECAUSE AGAIN,
IT'S NOT CONSISTENT.
LET'S FUND THE THINGS WE SAID WE
WOULD LIKE THE WALL AND PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS, WE SHOULD
STOP THAT.
>> Tucker: I DON'T WANT YOU TO
BEAT UP ON THE SPEAKER ON HIS
WAY OUT, BUT WHY DID WE END UP
WITH A SPENDING BILL LIKE THAT
SIZE?
>> WE TOOK IT TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE BEFORE THAT VOTE.
ONE WAS THE PLANNED PARENTHOOD
ISSUE AND ALL THREE MOVEMENTS
WERE NOT MADE IN ORDER BECAUSE
THEY WOULD HAVE PASSED.
THEY WOULD HAVE PASSED ON THE
HOUSE.
>> Tucker: WHO IS THAT?
>> THAT COMES FROM THE
LEADERSHIP COMMITTEE.
>> Tucker: PAUL RYAN IS MORE
FOR PLANNED PARENTHOOD?
>> IF THEY GET THROUGH SOMETHING
LIKE THE UNITED STATES SENATE
BECAUSE THE ARGUMENT IS IF YOU
MAKE THOSE AMENDMENTS IN ORDER,
THEY WILL PASS, THE BILL WILL GO
TO THE SENATE AND THEY WILL PASS
IT.
I'M TIRED OF THAT.
LET'S HAVE A DEBATE.
WE WERE -- CHUCK SCHUMER SET ON
THE GOVERNMENT OVER A WEEKEND
OVER AMNESTY AND THEY MAKE AND
PEOPLE SAID WE WILL THINK THAT'S
A SMART IDEA.
WE WERE POISED TO WIN.
INSTEAD WE DO WITH THE SWAMP